i think i saw ant-man reference a lot of
stuff going on on there too much too
right oh my god well i need this website
where is it yeah where's the website
give it to me
kyle went kyle went
kyle went he's got all the clothes
are you coming to la anytime soon
yeah probably not for a minute where are
you at i got some things where are you
at take care where are you at
oh
oh we're in space oh my goodness oh
always seeing his son i gotta talk to my
son or he's gonna beat me up
oh my god you're sylvester stallone i
got custody welcome back to new rock
stars she-hulk episode two confirms the
existence of wolverine in the mcu and it
ends by zipping bruce banner out into
space in a way that i wish i could leave
work zoom calls holy [ __ ] haley she-hulk
this is inside marvel new rockstar's
official after show for marvel's
she-hulk i'm eric voss with me is empty
and jessica clements hello friends
hi what's popping on me she-hulk episode
2 let's go
yeah interesting not as eventful of an
episode of she-hulk i think in terms of
like moving the platform i guess maybe
we just knew that these things were
coming we knew that she'd be
representing abomination from the
trailers but still very enjoyable i love
seeing jen with her family
i loved her connection with her dad
specifically and we got some
confirmation that ched cousin shed
ain't actually that smart they were they
were [ __ ] on today
oh you didn't get it you didn't get it
from the first time also i like that she
i think this episode is more about her
planning her feet as she holds she's
getting more confident and that's
something that i'm happy hits in the
second episode rather than like the
fourth or fifth so for everyone jessica
will be doing the easter egg breakdown
for episode two and for all of the
episodes for the rest of the season that
video that breakdown will come out a
little later today i can't wait to see
what jess found in this episode filled
with marvelous yes and she also did
episode one and so yeah yeah
yeah such a great job with that one it
was so great it's pretty damn good let
us recap what happened in this episode
the news of jen's she-hulk fight against
titania makes the rounds on local news
titania interestingly is called a super
influencer uh the chiron apologizes for
her actions attributes them to an
extreme case of low blood sugar so i
guess she just kind of knows i thought
that was interesting hey hey
hey
it does happen empty it does happen all
the time
it's true when you get low blood sugar
you turn into yeah i pick up a desk and
throw a strength woman i throw it at a
jury
yeah diabetes no joke it can bring out
the worst in all of us oh if you're not
good that's why there's die in diabetes
there you go and other people isn't it
as well and because it's something that
we all must recognize well jen is a hero
at the bar her boss the d.a fires her
after she saved the jury and her doing
that bias the jury so glk and h could uh
score a mistrial out of it so jen looks
for a new job including a website with a
ton of marvel easter eggs that jess is
gonna break down for us later but uh one
that we will talk about in this episode
is a man fights with metal claws in bar
brawl so wolverine is here folks and it
must be a slow news day because this is
the mcu in fighting with metal claws in
a bar brawl is pretty tame compared to
even our world where our bar fights
stories they hear coming out of daily
news sites in florida you know like a
man fights gator with metal claws maybe
and gator and man get high on bath salts
and get married overnight would be mine
what if that's what the writers meant
boss what if that's what they meant what
if it was just a florida man article and
it's just a guy with like garden sheer
gloves attacking right it could be that
probably
oh maybe it could be uh freddy krueger
you know freddie krueger want to be
fights uh scary terry fights in um
dade county uh 100
but yeah you're totally right that's
probably what i really hope it's not
just some random guy i really hope it's
i will pick up this
this this right here this this camera
and throw it out the window if they try
to give it to anything else i will lose
my mind i'll be that man in the bar
commit marvel commits i will be so mad
we get this wonderful moment where jen
visits with her family we meet her
mother elaine her father morris who's
played by perfect strangers mark lynn
baker i love that guy uh her aunt
melanie her uncle tucker her cousin chad
cousin chad kind of a dum-dum uh you
know i i really did think that there's
some brainiac ched in the family but
bruce is just being a [ __ ] when he
talks about a blessing oh because
he might be smarter they all know maybe
cousin chad is smart in other ways we
have yet to see maybe we're selling him
short he got promoted at best buy and
that is not an easy task and i'm not
that's true right it is hard to get
people
i've never been promoted not once in my
life i've worked at new rock stars for
uh
i don't know six years now and they
refuse to change my title i think i'm
still like researcher in my contract are
you intern in your country i think i
might be intern like they're so afraid
of making the executives of anything
because they're like
um
yeah so holden holloway from glk h shows
up at the bar offering jen a job running
their new superhero law division but it
requires her to be in she-hulk form at
all times which is a bummer come on but
jen gets nikki hired as her paralegal
and we meet pug whose gift basket
includes the best gift of all a map to
the best bathroom for a pooping which i
see as like maybe a joke from the rick
and morty writers room because there's
that whole episode where like rick had
been an entire planet
in private uh we know jessica gao was a
writer not on that season but i that had
to have been an inside joke of the rick
and morty writers room oh probably
they're kind of like dan hartman's like
i need this i just love the way it was
delivered it was delivered
perfect for the best bathroom
he's so perfect also uh this is just a
little behind the scenes for you new
rockstars doesn't have that bathroom we
have two bathrooms and it's in the
middle of the office so everyone can
hear it jess is lying to you she does
have a secret bathroom and she's just
trying to she's trying to rest off the
center unless it's the like cooler in
the back of the office there's no
bathroom here for you to poop in i think
that i think that room does exist it's
just tommy's office and you just gotta
keep that is true
he lures us in there yes
he's like please please
please poop right next
that bucket is connected to a pipe we're
like we don't see any pipes connected to
the first time he's like no
tell me there's no voice
here it's just a hole in the ground we
don't know what he's doing with it but
we trust that it's for scientific and
academic videos stop holloway assigns
jen the parole case of emil blonsky
abomination despite blonsky having
fought her cousin bruce in harlem he
actually signed that confidentiality or
uh not confidentiality wait he signed
the waiver he signed the waiver saying
like oh it's fine uh the conflict of
interest waiver it's i don't i don't
mind he wants her to represent him which
just feels sus to me like
you could have why why we'll find out
though jen enters this dodc super max
prison this is the same one that the
clandestines pretty easily broke out of
and ms marvel uh we get this little
silence of the lamb's parody speech uh
and i love that she says chianti the way
that uh uh hannibal says it in the scene
just says candy in such a weird way um
but uh we meet blonsky tim roth is back
my friends and he claims that he's been
rehabilitated he's all namaste he's
writing haikus now he says that it was
government's fault for giving him super
soldier serum that led to his actions he
has seven soul mates he drops that in
there or a man's got a medicine very
situation going on which i love like not
the fact that he has seven soul mates
but i feel like this could be a tease
for something later on at the end of
this year voldemort i'll talk about that
later voldemort it's the voldemort
no i think they're like they're teasing
like a dark avengers scenario where it's
just like hey like the people are trying
to break me out of prison so i can join
a team it's going to be me and seven
other people yeah there's something
sort of going for for sure i also just
think it's uh it's just interesting the
way he like talks and the way that he uh
seems to be rehabilitated and the fact
that it works on jen she's like wait a
minute the government gave you that
super soldier serum the she's pretty
hoodwinked
pretty quickly for an attorney you would
think she'd be like hmm interesting that
you say that you know what i'll look
into it if there's something there that
actually might be a good legal course
because the guy's totally lying right
like it wasn't the fact that he got that
initial injection of super soldier serum
that turned him into abomination it was
the fact that he went a step further and
got bruce's blood right didn't he get
the the serum from his blood
right at gunpoint i don't think
thunderbolt ross sanctioned that part of
it uh anyway no not i don't think
thunderbolt ross even knows what
happened i think he just extended the
truth like you know how like i was
loaned out to your government and then
he kind of blurred that in with like
they made me take all these things and
it's like well
no
right
he extended the truth the way you
extended the truth about there not being
a secret bathroom in the new rockstar's
office okay i'm not excited the thing is
i'm not extending the truth
evidence i wish i could take a photo for
you guys they're right next to each
other two toilets next to each other in
the middle of the office right i think
in this bathroom we'll find jess's list
ranking all the muppets
don't bring that back up again don't
bring that back up again i started a war
because of that list and i don't want to
get back into it i'm sorry i have to see
this list no exactly
so jen is moved she decides to take the
case she calls bruce to tell him about
it bruce says it's boy
oh he wrote me like
robia hi cool i'm okay with it but when
you find out that bruce is on this
sakarian courier craft he zips off to
space uh we'll talk about where he's
going but jen sees on the news that
video is leaked upon an abomination
fighting in that golden dagger's
fighting club in macau from chongqi
meaning that wong helped blonsky escape
prison now complicating blonsky's parole
and the post-credits scene shows that
jen is back at her family's house
helping morris and chad fix the car and
hang the tv and carry some water tanks
into the house but we gotta start by
talking about that
sink shark snake
snoozy
where is wolverine in the mcu right god
dang now
right
but we're gonna get to the bottom of it
we already know that mutants exist in
the mcu of course thanks to kamala khan
and ms marvel being identified as a
mutant and at d23 next month marvel will
announce the rest of their mcu mutant
plants i wrote plants but plans most
likely but plants might be the right
word there because they are planted and
sprouting like cabbage patch kids left
and right and really if you think about
it right now is the perfect time for
marvel studios to sneak in a few hints
to some famous x-men sprouting up all
over this universe and why not start
with wolverine right because man fights
with metal claws and barbra obvious not
the hugh jackman wolverine in that first
x-men film in 2000 the first marvel film
that our man kevin feige worked on as an
associate producer really just being the
smartest nerd in the room is what got
him the career he has today in the
control and mastery over everything
marvel in hollywood all started with
that movie you remember the scene rogue
finds wolverine cage fighting in a bar
in alberta canada but after logan wins
those matches using his regenerative
mutation his adamantium skeleton not
incurring a single scar he gets
confronted by a dude who lost some money
on bets our man pulls out a switchblade
what was he thinking roll the clip
look out
get out of my bar freak
he looks like a baby in the first movie
like a newborn baby boy yeah
such a young wolverine now we don't know
if it was this bar fight in particular
that the article was referencing or if
it was just a similar one that the 616
mcu version of wolverine inevitably got
into because that guy cannot walk into a
bar without like punching jukebox but my
assumption is that kevin feige plans to
recast wolverine in 616 yet still
acknowledge that the fox x-men film
continuity lives on and other universes
of the multiverse like you know with
patrick stewart playing professor x and
e3 8 and multiverse madness the
wolverine that universe probably was you
jackman would be my guest they all exist
it's all canon let's not fight about it
but the article describes logan as an
anonymous man with metal claw so that
must mean he's not yet famous in the mc
they didn't say mutant gets in fight
embark
like a man with bueno claus does what is
this thing i don't know uh but he's not
a member of the x-men yet he might not
have even met charles xavier yet would
be my guess however logan was always the
late arriving newcomer to the x-men so
for all we know xavier's mutants might
have already been secretly active in the
mcu we just haven't seen them yet my
theory has been for a long time that the
mutants were actually present during the
battle of earth an avengers end game
they arrived from their academy in the
neighboring westchester county of
upstate new york not even upstate new
york really it's just kind of like right
up north the hudson river in the mcu
xavier's uh academy might be right next
door to a venture compound and that
charles and scott and aroro might have
helped take down a couple leviathans on
another side of that rubble that we just
didn't see i would also just love level
of love if the rebuilding of avengers
compound could be
the new form of an expansion of xavier's
academy that could be where the danger
room or cerebro are built but i want to
ask you two do you think it's likelier
that mutants currently exist in 616 it's
just kind of a grass roots
unorganized spawning cabbage patches
popping up left and right and they
aren't really they don't even know what
they are yet or could there secretly be
active collectives of mutants like the
x-men the mutant brotherhood hellfire
club runaways etc etc currently
underground in this universe we just
haven't pointed the camera at them yet i
think that um the mutants have slowly
been coming out of the woodwork from the
events of avengers and games because
before end game we pretty much knew all
the super powered players there weren't
a lot of super powered happenings
happening in the mcu that we like that
weren't in a movie but now that we have
all these snaps that happened with
thanos snap we have tony stark snap we
have possibly even um
the hulk snap huge tons of radiation
like rocket says in um end game was
released onto the planet multiple times
and i feel like the population has
changed because of that and i'm thinking
that we're slowly seeing it what maybe
possibly with a titania as well because
we have this superpowered woman coming
out of nowhere like all right i got beef
it's like where are these super powered
people coming from it's like it's it
seems that like the post end game
universe is sort of like introducing
mutants because they've been mutated by
the radiations of the infinity stones
but that's i don't know that's just my
idea but i do like the idea of the x-men
being active and like actively fighting
during the battle uh between thanos
because like it would be incredible just
to see like a cutaway to their
perspective like oh man it'll be dope
that'd be dope as [ __ ] i i like you mg
you told me this theory before and i do
agree with it at the beginning with the
stones affecting how we have newtons now
but i also think that she-hulk will be
like our like start for them to start
actually finding each other i think when
he referred to when holden referred to
them as like um superhuman eccentric
superhumans i think those people don't
know yet that they're mutants and i
think that's when we're gonna start
seeing them coming out of the woodworks
and teaming up together is because we
have people like she hulk when they're
like yeah i'm just strong and i crushed
a car by accident and it's like oh well
you're actually a mutant uh like that's
when they're gonna start recognizing who
they are and what their abilities
actually mean so i do think in the 616
right now that what we're seeing of
wolverine he's not teamed up with anyone
and i don't think a lot of them are
because they don't know each other yet
but having these bigger platforms like
she-hulk they'll start finding each
other i think both of you are speaking
some truth here because it does seem
like that would be marvel studios plan
right to give some some causality and
some greater weight to everything that
happened in the infinity saga and like
if you think of phase four as uh you
know they even talked about as the
reactionary phase right to what happened
in the first three phases introducing
new characters and some of those
characters actually being
spawned or caused by all the radiation
releases by the infinity stones makes
makes a lot of sense i just want to see
the battle of earth again from a
different front i want to see cyclops
firing some lasers up in the leviathan
storm
causing a tornado maybe that that water
spout tornado that we thought dr strange
did all by himself maybe aurora was just
on the other side of a way to help him
help him a little bit helping a little
bit i want to see the battle of earth
with the x-men there
my toys all together
or at least in a what-if episode or
something i need to see it i need to see
it
sure that'd be fine i do wonder though
if like that robs the uh mutants of a
possible historical
uh origin story right like i think it's
pretty crucial to have
you know uh magneto eric lyncher's
origin story connected to world war ii
and if they're not going to do that
because obviously someone who's like
someone in their 60s now wouldn't have
been alive in the 1940s
you need to have some kind of like
genocidal refugee crisis to be part of
it to leave him with that spite toward
humanity uh so if he didn't exist until
a couple years ago you kind of lose that
opportunity i think for those bigger
characters like magneto that makes sense
also because i think that question is
still up in the air well it's not really
a question we kind of know the answer
but like they're like people are like
keep connecting it to scarlet witch
please connect it to scarlet witch so i
feel like those things can be addressed
in the mcu but i don't know if they're
gonna do the origin for wolverine
because it's been done so like we've
talked about it so much that i don't
know if disney wants to also touch on
that and be like hey ignore
the other movies that really focused on
him we're going to do it again
i might i could be completely wrong i
could be completely wrong my views on
what the x-men are going to be handled
like in disney plus is not
clearly everyone's favorite
i just
i i have i have beef
i have beef i guess well my thinking is
now you have an opportunity it like to
tell the true origin of wolverine which
is supposed to be connected to the super
soldier program of captain america right
like they were trying by by creating
adamantium they were trying to recreate
what they had with with steve rogers and
captain america and that's how we got
wolverine so we can truly say we can use
the word adamantium now we can use the
word mutant
uh we can establish how how old uh you
know um
logan was and how he might have been
connected to some of these things some
of these events like i i think we have
an opportunity here to to do it i think
the hard part though is to have a
character because not all the mutants
are supposed to be like slow aging right
and you'd have to get around that i
don't know if you could do world war ii
eric lyncher without making him like 120
years old or something like that right
or not i think that marvel studios may
actually be in like a really unique
position to actually do this because k
and like we know that like the multi the
timeline's all messed up and like
wormholes be opening so like i think
that kang dynasty is probably gonna be
how eric either goes through a wormhole
or
is somehow
you know retconned into the history of
the mcu so yeah i don't think that
marvel's probably gonna right around
that that's a good point empty i don't
know if you saw i gave you a golden
golden rogi bug for that
uh yeah you are right kang could
simplify a lot of these things my hope
though is i just don't want them to say
all mutants age really slowly i think
that's that was a really annoying thing
for me at least in the latter fox x-men
movies where you had characters like
hank mccoy and mystique who still
they looked like jennifer lawrence and
nicholas holt in the 60s and in the 90s
and that was never addressed like the
only characters in the mcu i mean i
guess with mystique she's a
shape-shifter so it works but like hank
mccoy is supposed to age like it doesn't
make sense that he still looked like
nicholas holt in the early 90s and in
the 60s and he's also supposed to be
blue
right
age for 30 years and like magneto is not
an ageless mutant he just controls and
manipulates metal like that's not
so i just don't want them to say like oh
if you're mutant you will look the same
across several decades like that's not
how it's supposed to be yeah it's not a
huge fan super soldier serum i'll all
allow i'll allow steve rogers aging very
slowly but not all mutants that's not
how it's supposed to be right anyway
this is very exciting time it just makes
me look forward to uh i just hope that
they can establish that like everything
we saw in the fox x-men films can still
exist in the multiverse and we don't
have to like erase all of that because
there was some great stuff that happened
in those movies not so great stuff
okay we want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode you know we all
want to hulk out in the bedroom when the
time is right i'm speaking to the
to the boys but also everybody out there
but sometimes you might need a little
blue to unleash the green and that
that's why this episode is brought to
you by bluetooth
confidence can take you far in life but
but it can help in the bedroom that's
where blue chew comes in blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
any time date or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready for whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days so it's all done online no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our fans try bluetooth
free when you use our promo code of
marvel at checkout just pay the five
dollars in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code marvel to receive your first
month free visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this show all right we have to talk
about the big question coming out of
this episode where is bruce going on the
sakara ship jess i'm going to throw this
one to you
i want to hear your theories for a while
okay i i okay monster school i'm sorry i
i've we've talked about it everyone's
talked about it yes i want to see scar i
just don't think we're gonna get into
scar actually showing up in she-hulk i
think we're planting the seeds for world
war hulk or even if we don't get like
that measure of world war hulk because
in world war hulk he's clearly uh just
in like angry and i don't think we're
going to get that from smart hulk but i
do think we're planting the seeds a
little bit of that in the situation of
like he's i think he went back to sakaar
after thor ragnarok that's why he has
all of his little knick-knacks and all
his souvenirs and he's just been going
back and i think they're reaching out to
him because he's the scientist now
that's leading a lot of operations there
on sakhar because we know that in world
war hulk and planet hulk that like his
blood can even just make grass and
flowers grow in the soil i think he's
studying a lot of the planet and i think
they're using him as their like
lead scientist so i think he's going
back to help with whatever research he
was doing when he left i just don't
think we're gonna he's going back to his
son and shot like his wife maybe we're
planting the seeds of his wife but i
don't think we're starting it is do you
guys do you guys agree with me am i
going crazy is that wrong no i think i
don't know
yeah yeah i think you're right on the
money there because like the i feel like
like bruce went to sakaar
to try to help them with their new
because they just freed themselves and
like no one can leave that planet
because like it's impossible to leave so
like they need a leader and like you
know bruce is like one of the smartest
people in the world so he's probably
just like all right i'll help you guys
build a society because i'm a nice guy
and uh you know and
that like like you said like those could
be the seeds for world war hulk because
now he like is sort of
in charge of these people he cares about
these people maybe he meets a girlfriend
and has a kid like and he's like hey jen
you seem to have things handled on earth
i'm gonna stay here because people need
me here you're the hulk for the for that
planet now um i feel that really fun and
i it would be really a nice seed for
world war hulk potentially and why
wouldn't you want like the strongest
because they love him on cigar
they had
millions of parades for him so why
wouldn't you want the strongest man that
you know in the galaxy to come protect
you guys on your planet because it's
like ever i would i'd be like this is
the strongest man bring him back to
watch us all and he's also smart
and do you think that um bruce will be
able to play that role because did they
love the personality of bruce banner and
they love
the badass aggro
monster dumbass that hulk was
i think they love the badass hulk okay
uh this is like uh the invention of
lying which is not good not a good
example for this movie
that's a good example but i'm just like
you have to show back up and be like
here's this or like idiocracy you need
to come back and be like here let me
teach you guys the what i can teach oh
this the car is not idiocracy but i'm
just saying it
is well you're right
god damn
goddamn it kind of is it really is
honestly but if you think about it it's
just like if you have someone that shows
up and spends the time to teach you guys
what's right and wrong and be like you
can use all
like all the trash that was there i'm
sure you can reduce reuse and recycle it
and use it into better things so it's
like yeah why don't i just i showed you
now i'm gonna leave and they're like no
wait come back we have more problems and
so i think it's gonna look like that
um they still probably want that like
aggressiveness but it's like you now
have like a leader that's a teacher uh
you have your maya rudolph if you will
for
idiocracy i don't think anyone watching
these has are you guys old enough for
idiocracy i guess that's an older movie
oh yeah oh we know especially now that
like idiocracy is basically the world
we're living in yeah
we're living it 100
before
there was idiocracy so keep that in mind
people watching basically
the blueprint the wall-e blueprint
idiocracy yeah uh i think going to
sakaar seems like the likeliest option
i'm just like curious why hulk seemed so
he didn't seem like worried at all he
seemed like he had a a steaming cup of
coffee there you know he's kicking his
dirty feet back up on the table he had
all his research and binders though so i
think he's just yeah i have to bring
some more stuff from my lab of tony's
starks industry tools to the cars to
finish my study
um but he didn't bring back the
evolution
yeah yeah i i know it's it's probably
far-fetched i just feel like if he's
going on an academic mission
like
it kind of seems like he'll he'd be
hooking up with
the high evolutionary with with adam
warlock like this is the the expert on
like what did uh tony start calling age
of ultron bio organics right like that's
what hulk knows he knows how gamma
radiation affects certain physiologies
like
part of me feels like he's gonna be
connecting with degree or some of the
other scientists who are the people who
invented the who invented adam warlock
in the comics
the enclave the enclave like i feel like
that would be somewhere that bruce
banner might be summoned to right now
like
understand how new species are invented
or how do we create the perfect being
like i don't know i would love that for
bruce banner in the future of the mcu
he's just traveling the planet by ship
where like uh captain marvel is just
zooming past every planet he's just like
i'm traveling to learn and research a
little bit more but also to teach them
right now he's on a ted talk tour yeah
yeah
i would love that
i would like that bruce banner smart
hulk all right let's move on and talk
about
emil blonsky abomination
there's obviously some questions over
why did wang help abomination escape i
assume we'll figure that out in future
episodes but like do we really think
blotsky's truly rehabilitated or do we
think he's full of [ __ ] i thought he was
at first i truly did but it is too
suspicious that he's asking for jennifer
walter specifically
and i am held on to that
like
why yeah unless it's to like be like i
want to confront you about
and make myself feel but it's like
you're not confronting hulk you're
confronting his cousin
and like he did leave out key details
about his transformation like you said
earlier it's like yeah you force someone
at gunpoint
to transform you into the abomination so
you should be in prison like that for
that alone uh right that's prison so
he's he's sort of he's playing her a
little bit so i don't the government
made me a super soldier
i was following orders listening to the
super soldier serum yeah like when he
was talking i was sort of kind of was
like oh man that's true because like he
kind of did just really want to be a
super soldier and like you know help
people but he did attach too much of his
own ego to that which is the bad thing
but like you know wanting to serve the
world isn't a bad thing i guess but you
know he's just using that to manipulate
jen and you know possibly the government
yeah because he in the movie wasn't it
more so that he was just like i really
want to beat him like we need something
else that can beat him and then they
made him they gave him the super soldier
soda and he got swung against a tree
[Laughter]
kicked to a tree
and he was like i still need to beat him
like it was more so his own agenda than
it even was the government oh yeah he
went raw ego yeah but i mean he does i
guess at the end of the day have a point
that if people like
you know bucky barnes can walk around
free
right with like a government kind of
like pardon it doesn't really make sense
i i agree with him for that point
because i'm like if anything hulk should
be locked up in here with me as well
like oh for sure
right
sokovia and like all that [ __ ] that
hulk did like yeah and it's
like in my breakdown
so jen's dad mentions like you're a hulk
and at least you didn't destroy like a
city and i wrote down i have like a
scroll list of everything he's destroyed
in the mcu and the thing is the list is
genuinely comical about how long it is
he also should be in prison
the amount of times and at least
abomination now is like oh actually
never mind
never mind abomination is fine i was
about to spoil it i was about to spoil
something i stepped back i stepped back
well thank you for stepping back from
that ledge my friend
we would understand though um but i
think the he
you are right they should all be in jail
and didn't we hear that the soviet
courts are going to come up on this
series like
this is going to be a gorgeous make them
all criminals they should all be in jail
yes right straight to jail i honestly
i feel like something's happening and
this is maybe this
tinfoil had mt but like something is
happening where i feel like someone is
preying on the fears of of superhumans
to try to control
of the mcu society i feel like
um
like either they're making superhumans
or like i feel like hydra is probably
orchestrating a conflict so like oh yeah
we need like um we need the dodc to have
more power and we need like um our own
avengers to like fight all this new
threat and um i feel like that's sort of
what new new world order might be about
um but i don't know i just feel like
this this holloway guy um super sketchy
and like his first his first case for
jen is the parole of emil blonsky like i
don't know what's going on but like it
feels like a dark avengers is forming
right now yeah i think you're right mt i
do think thunderbolts slash dark
avengers is behind a lot of this i think
we're gonna have scene with holloway and
val and val's just gonna slide a brief
briefcase full like vibranium over to
holloway always like i don't know what
to do with this i can't even lift it
look
just i'm too weak i'm too old
uh but i think you're right um i want to
end with the discussion of this question
what do we think jen accidentally said
she was agnostic toward when holloway
asked her a question while she was doing
her voice over to us she said i'm going
to ask myself that question all year i
feel like we're going to find out what
she said she was agnostic too but i want
to hear both of your thoughts on what
she said that what she said what because
he brought up money money money money do
you remember that lying that he says
like when she's like none of these guys
ever had to deal with it and he's like
oh money money money money
like mr krabs i think it was probably
like an exaggerated like you know
because she's like talking to the
breaking the fourth wall like yeah he's
just saying random [ __ ] he's like
money money money money doesn't matter
um but no the agnostic line uh i just
thought it was like a funny throwaway
line but like it could i don't know
potentially
be something in terms of like i don't
know the fact that she can break the
fourth wall it's like i don't believe in
a god i talk to god all the time
and he's the viewer this is like this is
um
it's i mean not believe in a guy it's
like i don't know who's out there but
i'm talking to somebody out there
yeah don't know
what's out there but you believe in some
type of higher power i guess it could
also mean just like not but i don't it's
so weird agnostic is a word that can be
used and framed in different ways other
than religion i feel like uh
i was imagining it was because like she
was like he was like i'm the head up
money money money here all these guys
are also the head up who are opposite of
you how do you feel about it and she's
like i
don't believe in any of it
it's just like it means nothing to me
and he's like oh strange it'd be funny
if she just brought up her religion
[Laughter]
he was like interesting unprecedented
certainly
like so my thinking is that he was going
off on how people were like trying to
sue the avengers for what thanos did or
something like that he's like well what
do you think about what thanos did and
she goes i'm agnostic to it like maybe
she accidentally said that they just did
nothing
oh okay
i saw that written on a
on a times square urinal at some point
otherwise and the person that wrote it
was me in a legal setting unprecedented
it
was
researchers to say that uh yeah or like
maybe she's like accidentally said that
like
you know maybe there was like a
discussion that kill grave was going
around or that arrows and he's like what
do you think of if a super villain were
to uh brainwash someone into loving them
is that sexual assault and she goes i'm
agnostic to that he goes
unprecedented also what is that
what is that just like her way of
getting out of conversations that she
clearly wasn't paying attention to you
know how actively people just go like
yeah yeah and then people are like i
asked a question it's like oh [ __ ] uh i
feel like that was her way of just like
that's her key phrases like i'm agnostic
and that's why she's like i'm gonna be
thinking about this for the entire year
why did i say that and what did he say
for me to say that i think i think by
the end of the season she's going as a
result of that conversation get assigned
to defend uh johnny mayonnaise john
walker
to using captain america's shield in
like a horrible public murder uh and
that's why
[Laughter]
you said you were agnostic to it
you said you were agnostic i i i think
it's hilarious that like her answer that
she was like agnostic is in the mcu
considering that the avengers one of the
avengers is a god so she's like is
anybody agnostic anymore like is anybody
an atheist like is it possible to be an
atheist
because gods yeah
i think
are you talking about the god being the
two gods of cap's butt cheeks because
i worship at the altar
something
i'd love to thunderclap
[Music]
we'll leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel uh thank you so much to
jess clements and to mt follow them on
uh social media for just at lulu
underscore clements mt mastertainment
follow me at ea boss subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you so much for watching be sure
to check out jess's breakdown coming
later today i'm sure it's gonna be
amazing and we will see you all next
week thank you everyone for watching bye
you